aller les marseillais au grand projet
c'est d'ouvrir très grande bibliothèque
dans les quartiers nord de marseille
moi j'ai arrêté l'école très tôt
peut-être troisième moi je pense que la
culture ça va sauver lé envie de
découvrir ma vie d'apprendre d'autres
langues l' envie de faire de l'avant le
savoir vivre et le savoir être le savoir
ur le savoir est ça passe par
l'éducation
et quand tu es capable toi-même de
telvent et lectures helmand gros tu peux
casser des barrières dames on n'attend
pas que tu sois un nom bien soit un nom
bien et attend la mort j'ai gaspillé le
temps au creux de serveurs se sont
amenés ici je vais vous montrer mon
marseille à moi
rappeur des quartiers nord je me la pète
aussi je suis réalisateur parce que j'ai
fait deux séries qui a fait deux
épisodes qui ont super bien marché
activiste pour les quartiers nord et
pour sa ville de marseille les futurs
hummer ya un deuxième album qui va
sortir s'appelle mistral
et la piste une
c'est une musique on a déjà sur gc
l'intro du projet qui commence par un
simple d'une
écrit par daniel boys
non
et au plus tôt
1 jusqu'au vieux-port préveraud
signification
cette rose 1982 je t'ai pas né elhadj
combat
la rencontre de monsieur daniel boys
c'est bono
tantôt
mais masquée mots cela fait comme je
l'avais mois ce qui combattent mon salut
sauce je suis désolé je ne serre pas la
main oui vous avez bien au delà des bons
jours
en tout cas je suis ravi de vous
rencontrer de pouvoir et ben moi aussi
moi aussi merci pour l'invitation
en fait j'ai été professeur de musique
au collège camus proposé aux élèves
d'écrire une chanson est la première
chanson dans la tête c'est justement
celle ci les jeunes de marseille et hull
à la marche pour l'égalité en 83 qu'on
appelle un peu attendre marche-t-elle
bercy dans sur les jeux david avoir est
comme ça tous ces jeunes qui sont partis
une poignée de marseille il ya eu comme
un livre comme sort et paix à paris
c'était 100 milles et on a entendu à la
télé les jeunes de basse elle qui chante
et ça a pris la pose avec inventé de
marseille jusqu'à ce que ça marche
qu'est ce que vous croyez que si vous
attendez la meilleure pour nous si c'est
possible on demande pas la lune aux
demandes de vivre c'est tout mais
l'authenticité de mes fans je vais pas
pleurer sûrement précarité mais montrer
au monde qu'on est capable ce maillage
et qu'ils en feront pareil tétouan
transfert des messieurs je viens vous
épaulé mais je suis quand même cross sur
la canebière je vais rappeler la rue et
tous ces problèmes là on est au collège
clair soleil et un collège qui est
important pour moi parce que c'est là où
c'est que j'ai basculé de l'enfance à
l'adolescence kitsch adolescence j'ai
envie et passion de caen
j'ai patient je dérape et quand je le
dis rap dj
grasset
personnage c'est une belle époque en
fait moi j'ai découvert ici je les pions
et sert à queue
j'ai vu ce sont madness je connaissais
déjà avant parce que je savais qu'ils
savaient ils rappent et depuis l'âge de
11 ans il faut savoir que ça des
réponses à voile assad mixte il faut
savoir que c'est quelqu'un que même
quand j'ai arrêté le rap
on a vu deux équipes
tu vois ça j'aime pas trop parler de ça
mais qui m'a rencontrée dans une période
de ma vie où je faisais vraiment
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas hésité à
déjà se rappeler de moi parce que oui la
lune sa carrière mais moi j'étais un mec
de la boucan
d'autres qui n'hésitait pas à me dire où
j'étais bon j'étais bon à l'école
j'étais au collège
qu'est ce que tu fais une analyse assez
paul brochu match en train de prendre
etc
de par son personnage de par les
discussions qu'on avait tout ça je
sentais que c'était un petit gamin qui
avait du potentiel qu'avait les choses à
dire et moi je dis toujours une phrase
de scred connexion que j'adore c'est
mauvais départ ne veut pas dire arriver
forez c'est à dire mais peu importe le
parcours que tu as eue entre guillemets
dans la rue parce qu'on en fait on est
tous deux amoureux
on est tous des quartiers on est tous et
on n'est pas forcément vous
et c'est quelqu'un vraiment qui veut
parler de moi dans ma carrière de la rue
c'est lui j'ai eu la chance
6 heures
je vais te raconter une anecdote la tête
ma mère j'avais sur la tête ma mére
j'avais déjà vécu dans une école mais on
profite s'appelait monsieur guay c'était
un renoi de 2 m bon une fois je m'en
moque comme avec mon pote saad bouh
c'est sur le bon dieu qu'est ce qu'on
vient on est ancienne on se met un coup
de poing dans la vitre guidon casque et
ferrero il nous prend il nous fait
rentrer dans une pièce pic noir
il ferme la porte il faisait quoi nous
as tu pas battez vous faire part fonds
vers zéro battez vous
[Musique]
à
ça
je vois la serre où les plus jouissives
ou n'est plus qu' on a une équipe
supérieure techniquement et physiquement
tu veux dire qu'il a peur non non on va
dire qu'on voit pas aller jusque là à
mes 10 ans qui n'aime pas il fait tout
drôle a déjà tué dit on à 37 38 ans
amène des gens de notre génération pour
face à mu il est parti de prendre un
joueur de la cfa 2 il est parti prendre
un gode internationale il ya un
freestyler il prend le ballon il a fait
disparaître un moment donné je suis dit
ah oui tu sais quoi et sur la vie de ma
mère que je te demande pas ça tu vas
jouer trois quarts d'heure ou gold votre
aise balle et puma voilà c'est futsal à
une complexe sportif que j'ai ouvert il
ya un an de ça avec deux associés c'est
à dire qu'on est sur du sport je crois
aussi qu'on est sur du dépassement de
soi et ne vise pas le dépassement de soi
c'est c'est c'est une valeur qui parfois
peut nous manquer dans les quartiers
nord et c est toi moi aussi c'est la
première fois que je viens et
franchement je suis agréablement surpris
décidé après les félicitations
j'ai le sourire parce que je me dis ça
cheuvreux je me dis ça tu avais uchenna
tu as un milieu de du 13 14 le 15 un
bitume c'est saverot montrer à ce [ __ ]
de monde que des enfants d'immigrés qui
on a eu des parents des grandes familles
qui ne savent pas parler la langue
comprendrait le business c'est sa plume
avec qui arrive à faire de belles soyez
fiers fiers comment state soyez fiers
soyez fiers des gens de vos communautés
soyez fiers des gens qui réussissent
soyez fiers d'eux des gens qui essayent
de faire de grandes choses pour vous et
les gens qui vous ressemble pour télé
puisque comme vous aller les porter ça
va faire du bien vous ne soyez pas
jaloux mais que ça sert à rien j'ai pu
qu en parle avec fierté
on était quartiers nord on est des on
est des endroits très compliqué de la
france est autant lui que moi dans le
domaine extra rap on peut dire à quel
point c'est compliqué tout avec mon
enfant verte à l'heure c'est très
compliqué c'est à dire que nous on a
d'autres facteurs à faire entrer en jeu
dans la musique on n'est pas que des
rappeurs tu vois ce que je te dire gros
tu pourras pas comprendre mais il ya des
facteurs très compétentes à prendre en
compte qu'on peut qu'on pourra jamais
qu'on pourrai jamais dire à l'écran mais
qui sont très compliquées et qu'on perd
et très cher pour pas les avoir et être
cool être qu'on pousse et rappeur allé
au studio machin à l'anis inventé une
vie est rentré chez soi
nous on est des quartiers nord essayez
notre resto c'est une autre histoire
sachons
[Musique]